i'm excited for the future of retail
because i think that you're going to see
a ton of new
concepts at stores that are going to be
like fun
like i'm excited to go to retail in 2035
because i know they're going to be
forced to do more than just have it
there
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
do you think there have been any kind of
major winners over this time
either people or brands who kind of
taken and ran with this
a hundred percent i mean you have a
whole slew of
micro entrepreneurs that started mask
brands and things that nature
and then at the macro level you have
direct consumer brands that have
massively succeeded during this time
anybody who's in the dtc
or e-commerce um
infrastructure game has benefited
greatly and those who
are not and have relied on physical
um situations has has struggled to some
degree so
you know there's been um there's always
winners and losers when there's a
sea change and um i think the biggest
winners are
um direct to consumer infrastructure
businesses whether it's
the delivery mechanisms aka the pipes
and the shovels and
things of that nature or brands that are
within that ecosystem so
i guess one of the positives um out of
all this
is it has forced some brands who are
resistant
to kind of i guess jumping
feet first into digital marketing and
social media gets serious
do you think that will ever go away
again do you think there'll be a natural
correction
once the pandemic is over or are we are
we here to stay there has been a sea
change
i think we're here to say i think
they'll be uh back to for
using water there's some leveling down
but it won't go to
pre-covered levels i think a lot of
people have come to learn
the incredible importance of you know
communicating
in a modern way um and so
no i think a lot of brands have built up
new muscles
and um it's kind of like adding leg
workouts or cardio workouts here
to your workout regimen you're going to
now you know
factor it in um and i think you know
the most conservative will go back at
some level
to you know some of their old ways but i
think
the majority of organizations have
realized there's incredible
opportunities
in in some of these digital landscapes
and i think they'll
go deeper into those waters
so then kind of the same question but on
the other side of things has this
affected how
people consume content and interact with
brands is that going to be a lasting
effect as well
yeah i mean i think yes i think people
have discovered a lot of new things
whether it's tick-tock whether it's
a new ott platform like peacock or if
they've added one
whether that's hulu most people have
netflix um
uh i think that interacting with brands
from a you know how do you buy them
standpoint has changed dramatically
um i think people have discovered new
brands because they're in their phones
and their feeds a lot more um i think
video infrastructure i mean
this interview there's a 50 chance that
maha and i would have booked this on one
of our two or three trips a year
and we would be doing this over a coffee
i think
i think all of us are dramatically more
comfortable with video conferencing
and um and i think you'll you'll see the
effects there
do you think that's going to spill over
because you obviously do
a lot of events you you kind of talk at
a lot of different events is this going
to spill over into into that space
um yeah yeah
i do i believe it will and i think
you're seeing that as well i think
you know you'll have more virtual
conferences um
i i think there's there's a sea change i
do think
humans inherently in our depths of being
animals
like being around each other so i do
think you'll
see in 24 36 months plenty of concerts
plenty of conferences
but i do think you'll have additional
virtual events
and i think that some of those uh
conferences and concerts won't won't
come back i think that one will be a
smaller percentage but i i do believe
that
yeah i do believe that's the case so
then
kind of on that i think this pandemic
has put an awful lot of
uncertainty into people's minds and i
think even the most
die-hard self-starters right now might
be doubting themselves
so i was kind of wondering kind of on
that theme if in your journey did you
ever doubt yourself
or have you ever been scared that a
business decision or an investment
might fail um
i've been thoughtful in knowing that i
was doing things that were high risk and
had
a potentially high percentage chance of
not succeeding
but i either a needed to
taste it like i just genuinely needed to
um see it through like i was just too
curious
to to not not do it um
i don't really fear i've never done
anything in business
that if it fails i have to
remarkably change my lifestyle i have to
sell my home i have to
you know i've never done that kind of
behavior and then even more importantly
i've never been scared to play humble
meaning
humbly accepting defeat and definitely
humbly in my lifestyle
so i've never i've never um worried
about
that i mean that that fear in business
has almost never been a variable for me
um and so the answer is not
really and i and i think it's important
for people to hear this i'm not
saying that i always think it's going to
be great and i'm overconfident
it's just that when i know i'm in
losing situations or potential losing
situations
i mentally uh corked my wine social
network from 2009
failed felt very confident that it might
because i wasn't running the business i
was
i bought it i put somebody in place i
was stretched in between wine library in
the start of vaynermedia and i just
wrote a book
like i knew that it might not work and i
would lose money that's what happened
um you know uh uh
buying something called lost letterman a
sports
media site failed when i integrated it
into vaynermedia years ago
but um but i wasn't concerned about it
because i learned a lot which led to me
making the acquisition of purewow.com
and building a true media conglomerate
uh vayner
live and vayner events failed
twice i had you know executives one
who's still a tremendous friend it just
didn't click and
another one that she went on to wanting
to do some stuff on her own
um but i've learned a lot about live
event
marketing and feel very confident that
when i get into it
uh if i get into it i'm now in a
different place and all of those were
losses and all of those were six or
seven figure losses
but didn't put me out of business and
and and taught me quite a bit and more
importantly
not the kind of thing that i feel any
shame or concerned about
um i'm thrilled for the executions and
the learnings
and the fact that i get to play for
another day and i i think more people
need a great relationship with losing
and fear
when it comes to business i think people
have to recalibrate it i think too many
people struggle with outside opinions
about their wins or losses
for me i try to keep it in a very narrow
pocket of like the cheering and the
booing
is all kind of the same and i just got
to keep focusing on the goal at hand
i was gonna say you're um you come
across as quite a self-confident
person um and you're more than happy to
bet on yourself
um and again that kind of not listening
to other people's opinions
is effectively kind of why where does
that come from
because i think a lot of people right
now i think really good parenting yeah
you know
i mean dna for sure at some level but
you know my mom created a very confident
and consequence-driven environment uh
meaning she she she reinforced
my kindness and who i like they all
caught up quote the right things
but there was enormous amounts of merit
you know uh
when i would have a bad baseball game i
would remember i would try to come up
with an excuse she suffocated it when i
got
bad grades i would be grounded
so there was consequences but there was
a lot of confidence
and and and and i honed my skills you
know i think
entrepreneurship got so cool business
got cool
in this last decade and
a lot of people jumped in but a lot of
those people were artists
a lot of those people were students a
lot of those people
um you know grew up in a manner where
they did
other things i have been honing my
business skills since i was six years
old for real
for real like truly 80 70 60
of my childhood was shoveling snow for
five bucks
making lemonade and selling it all day
washing cars
like literally washing cars um
[Music]
it was that it was that like that that's
what i did
you know one summer was spent strictly
building a miniature golf course
in my friend's backyard and then selling
tickets to play the course
like you know it was and then once
baseball cards and sports cards kicked
in
at 12 11 it was game over that was the
next six years of my life
and then by then i got dragged into my
dad's liquor store and started doing
you know son of a you know the son of a
merchant life so
i've been in a business cocoon my whole
life at 44 i'm a
old man in business terms because most
people get into the game in their 20s
so i i feel like a 65 year old from an
experience standpoint
so then i guess what would be your
advice
to someone i guess thinking about
potentially starting a new business or
someone who
maybe has just started a business and is
getting hurt because obviously they
can't make
that experience they can't conjure it
out of thin air
meaning as in if you you can rely on the
fact that you have been kind of
in business for so long um which allows
you to be self-confident
is there any way for someone who may not
have had that experience do i guess
i don't know yeah no i think it's a
great question no no i i understand now
i apologize uh
look you can't you can't
fabricate it so i think the number one
thing is you go in
recognizing you're naive i do that quite
you know it's funny
i appreciate the confidence um
statement but i will tell you i really
enjoy humility too like i like
knowing i don't know i'll give you an
example right now i'm incredibly hot on
sports cards
i've been talking about it a lot and
we're seeing it all over i actually sold
a bunch of
messy rookie cards uh excuse me i bought
a bunch of messy rookie cards
from somebody in dubai so this is
starting to get global especially with
proper football being a global sport and
we're starting to see soccer
mumbai i mean you can't imagine what's
going on with his
cards and stickers nonetheless
i had a seven year career being a
baseball card dealer from
11 to 18 and two years ago when i
realized something was happening
i spent six months reading and learning
before i jumped back in and i had a lot
of context
yeah but i had the humility to know that
i was rusty
and there was a lot of things that
changed so to the person that you're
asking
i would tell them to go in with naivete
which is a strength a lot of times but
with deep humility
and and you know i see a lot of these
well-educated kids
kids of wealthy and successful um
go in and think they're gonna kill it
and their overconfidence
and lack of experience
disproportionately ends the game before
it started
to read up um so let's talk about this
new world order for a second um
everyone is buying and selling things
online right now and i think that what
has happened is
it that kind of broke the habits of even
those who previously preferred to go to
physical
locations does this spell the end for
traditional brick and mortar is this the
the final nail in the coffin
no no no i think it well
it's the nail in the coffin for certain
brick and mortar brands that have
terrible leases no real
dot-com infrastructure and they're
finished
but what you're gonna see is you're
gonna see the leases restructure
you know it's all supply and demand if
you've got a you know you know
and i think you'll see retailers
re-innovate i think we're going to have
a
i'm excited for the future of retail
because i think that you're going to see
a ton of new
concepts at stores that are going to be
like fun
like i'm excited to go to retail in 2035
because i know they're gonna be forced
to do more than just have it there
yeah and so i think you'll see more
things like genius bar
right you'll you'll have more you know
help more you what i would call
utility yeah i think you're gonna have
more entertainment
i i mean think about this if you're a
beauty brand a store retailer and you
want to go after alta
and sephora i would do something
where i created an a beauty influencer
inside my store 300 i would call my
brand
365 beauty and the concept is
all 365 days every store
has a major beauty influencer in that
store doing
product signing demos like you can i
just made that up on the spot
so like you know to me that you're gonna
see people
innovate and so i think to your question
yes brands that we know lord and taylor
you know you'll see some
big brands that everyone grew up with
toys r us
go in america many in dubai that will
quote unquote go away
what i think you'll see come from that
is a whole new breed
of experiential brands um
and paying leases that they can afford
with margins that they can afford
and i think it's going to be pretty cool
actually to be honest with you
it sounds like you're describing
physical retail
locations as as a platform a hundred
thousand percent
because we're not going to live we're
not at the vr
stay in your home for life stage yet
you know and so i don't see a world
where
we don't have retail as a meaningful
part of the component
i just think it's not as we know it
today
and guess what retail looks a lot
different than it did 50 years ago
and in a weird way it doesn't and that's
why i think it's time
to see a huge reset so uh
media brands are feeling this as well
um basically anyone who relied on
selling eyeballs to other brands to make
money
and obviously you know a thing or two
about kind of the advertising industry
um and getting people to engage with
your content so i guess the quick the
question is is can anything be done
um to save traditional media
no i think you're seeing the same thing
you know look traditional media
again newspapers are still being printed
i'm not sure that i would have believed
that in 1995
so what that experience taught me is
look things
get dented they don't die right
and so um to me give me one second i
just want to write that down i like that
things get indented
i wrote it down too um so i think
traditional media will get dented what
do i mean by that network and cable as
you and i know it
i think will get dented because ott will
eat up a lot of that
but i do think in 15 years there is
cable and network tv
i just think that it's looks like
newspaper now
like it's like i don't think you and i
know a whole lot of 40 and unders that
read the newspaper every day
no um but i'll
even pick up a newspaper at a hotel and
read the front page
for two seconds or skim it but it's like
an afterthought and you have 70 and 60
and 80 year olds that will read it and
so i think i think that's what you'll
see i think ott internet
video will eat up uh
cable and television as we know it and
then i mean if you're saying traditional
media
if we're talking marketing i mean it's
incredibly crazy to see
something made for a television
commercial i'm i'm hoping that
you know with ott people will make
longer form videos
more creative videos but the format
looks to be sitting the same which is
you're trying to watch this hulu show
or this show on roku or amazon or
netflix
you know and and here comes a video for
five seconds to interrupt you
yeah so the format hasn't changed a
whole lot just yet
but i do think the context of the
platforms and the
and the targeting capabilities that
these you know
you're going to be able to target on
television the way that you target it on
facebook and instagram and i think
that's going to
create a whole new variable that i'm
excited about marketing in
so what about because obviously you you
are in the the media space as well
uh how is purewow doing uh how is that
done over the past couple
couple weeks and months quite well
actually i think last year was an
interesting challenge for the gallery
media group
which also houses 1 37 p.m we launched 1
37 p.m
we launched a podcast you know platform
where we have multiple shows
so we're doing a lot of investing which
always leads to financial challenges
we had a little bit of we had some shake
up at the you know sales team level and
it's actually been remarkable ryan
harwood and i talk
almost every day now about the notion of
like it's
stunning to see how
successful we've been able to be during
this time now there's a reason
gallery media group aka purewow in 137
we sell content driven advertising more
than banners
and emails and right now everybody's in
need of
content because they can't do live
action
yeah for commercial things that nature
so and we and to be very frank it's also
been our own behavior we've been able to
spend a lot more time
with senior executives on zoom and all
these platforms
and have absolutely been able to
make bigger relationships and create
business opportunities
uh for ourselves so i guess to move from
brands to individuals
you know i i know that it's certain
influencers have also been
hit a little bit because again anyone
who gets paid to get eyeballs onto
products
um do you think that they're gonna
bounce back much quicker than
again a brand or a business i would
argue they have back
bounced back i think those articles may
be something you're referring to is a
little premature i think if you go talk
to the top
5 000 influencers the way i kind of pay
attention to
and they have they've like there's
individual influencers who've been
affected but that
happens every day covet no covet yeah
but um you know the top influencers have
been doing just fine
yeah well i guess it's natural to move
on now to uh
which appears to be one of the kind of
bigger biggest winners of all this you
know with their
sudden captive hungry audience and
there's obviously no doubt that it's
really boomed
but obviously there's an awful lot of
uncertainty which seems to be coming out
in
in almost real time now i think uh it
could be banned in the u.s microsoft has
now said it's interested
um and the news changes every day but i
guess the first question is
what would you say to people who have
boomed on the platform
um and are now facing the uncertainty of
it may be banned and that may all
go away proof i hope that they've been
listening to me and other people who've
been yelling for
a long time that if you're not
diversifying you're vulnerable
you know vine went poof snapchat's
growth was stagnant
you know dane cook and tila tequila were
superstars on myspace
um you know uh i i i believe that you
need to be everywhere
but not beholden to anywhere okay and um
and if you look at the top stars addison
ray charlie
and dixie dimiglio they've been able to
build unbelievably large audiences
in other places like instagram and
youtube and twitter
so i think they're incredibly um
well positioned but i'm sure for them
like all of us nobody wants to lose the
platform that they're most
engaged on or winning on but i always
i also reminded a lot of tick tock stars
that i spoke to during this time
you know if that platform disappears
well all those eyeballs go somewhere and
they're going to be spread between
instagram and youtube and twitter and so
keep that in mind and so you know it
does look like
there's a deal to be had now with tick
tock and microsoft
in the us we'll see i mean obviously
we have a very unpredictable
you know political situation in america
so um i'm not sure but i'm prepared for
look i'm prepared
for the internet to be banned yeah you
know like
then i'll go outside and make signs like
you know like to me like
you know it is what it is and so you
just have to adjust
just like i promise you nowhere on my
roadmap
was covid sit at home for a year
yeah um i'm a counter puncher
by nature and i think every influencer
every business person
every executive every entrepreneur needs
to take on that
mindset because you're just not in
control of everything
so then if you're a business or a brand
or an influencer and you're not yet on
tick tock
is it worth waiting for all this to blow
over or do the rules still stand
i think the biggest i think the biggest
thing people miss is of course it's
worth it here's why
learning how to create on the platform
will help you on the next platform
you know it's like if you missed why
this worked
you don't have the consumer insight to
why it worked thus making you vulnerable
to the next thing
yeah so this is not about selling stuff
on tick-tock or massing a million fans
this is about understanding why billions
of people like something
so that you can then make other
decisions going forward i believe that
my momentum as a marketer
continues to grow because of my
understanding of mediums
so what what appears to be working on on
tick tock then
from your content in your experience
what
what hasn't what has attracted so many
people there and what sort of what does
it take to go big
i think the ease and the lightness of it
is very
you know the music and the trends make
it easier for people to be content
creators
i think it's given people training
wheels you don't have to necessarily
be able you have you don't have to do it
all yourself the filters and the music
puts you on third base
so the production value that comes along
with the
platform inherently has put people on
the platform i think being authentic
works so i think a lot of people
um are winning because they're just
being their natural self and people like
authenticity a lot
and so that i think is really working
and i think people that are not working
are
people that don't like to dance that are
dancing
because they think that's what's working
i think what's not working
is trying to fit into something that
isn't you
i'd rather people do what they think
you know what they know so another big
winner of the last couple months has
been
esports and now obviously there's a lot
of intent um
increased attention on esports leagues
um and by a lot of people who
i guess never thought that they would be
interested in it and i know that you
have taken the vested
interest in it um do you think that it's
it's gone
mainstream do you think this is it now
now looking back
yeah and again to be frank i feel like
that was the case pre
you know that obviously i invested in
the minnesota rocker
you know uh league and the call of duty
league
prior to covet i think all of this was
inevitable
i think the esports landscape is going
to continue to grow and
um yeah i mean i think this was all kind
of inevitable
so i guess kind of what's next for for
for you
you know you've said you've said kind of
previously that you know we're probably
going to be
staying at home or at least you guys are
um for the foreseeable future and
obviously next year is going to be
affected
um have your kind of plans changed
not too much you know watching consumers
looking for opportunities
running the vaynerx world it's a big
world uh you know
obviously the speaking bureau vayner
speakers has been affected the most
production vpro vayner productions
second
everything else is kind of humming along
um obviously with singapore and london
we have enough globalization that
certain markets may shift and do
different things
um but no i'm just kind of focused on
what i do which is
build and operate businesses and look
for opportunity and
that's where i'm at well then i was
actually going to say because we talked
about it a little bit earlier
um i've kind of been following websites
like um
it's like taobao and and kind of
the services consumer we're not consumer
to consumer
uh brand to influencer all live stream
shopping is that something it's
something that's gone
kind of gangbusters in china uh that's
100 gonna happen
in the rest of the world a hundred
percent qvc at scale is something i've
always believed in
yeah and um i
uh i couldn't believe in it more um
um so kind of this is it this is the
last question um and it's one close to
my heart because i have over the
pandemic
started a youtube channel which is a bit
of an experiment
because i think deep down people want to
interact with people and not necessarily
brands
and i was wondering if you agreed with
that um and what advice you might have
for me or any other
fresh-faced youtuber or would-be
influencer out there
yeah people you know there is no brands
there's usually people with a brand
right there's no like baseball bouncing
around it's me with the baseball so yes
i agree with that
i would say put out what you want to put
out and then read the comments and reply
to the comments
it's the community that creates the
blueprint of success and i think too
many people
miss that part of it well perfect well
thank you very much
thank you for having me no worries stay
safe you too my friend
hey everybody on youtube first of all
thank you so much so humbled for your
time
i don't want to watch but time is the
biggest asset so thank you for watching
that video
if uh if you got some value out of that
there's a plenty more where that came
from
feel free to check it out